The reasons behind their exclusions may vary,
but here's a look at some DCEU characters who
all share a common thread: disappearing from
a superhero mega-franchise without a trace.
These are the characters who
disappeared without explanation.
Will Smith's Floyd Lawton, also known as Deadshot,
is introduced in Suicide Squad as a master
marksman who never misses his target.
He's also shown to be a devoted father to his
daughter, Zoe. After being incarcerated, Deadshot
is recruited as a member of the government-run
Suicide Squad team. From there, he helps defeat
the film's nefarious villain Enchantress,
before being put back in his prison cell.
Originally, this was to be just the
start of Deadshot's journey in the DCEU.
Five months before Suicide Squad premiered,
Variety even reported that Smith was reprising
his role as Deadshot in a sequel to
the movie. By the end of that year,
various reports noted that a spinoff movie about
Deadshot was in development. In 2018, Smith said:
"They've been talking about it.
So if a good idea comes around,
we've been having meetings. But I
would love to. I love Deadshot."
In the years since, however, there's been
little word about Deadshot having any
further presence in the DCEU. Reflecting
his diminished status in this franchise,
Deadshot wasn't even referenced in
Harley Quinn's solo movie, Birds of Prey.
However, there's still hope for the character's
return. According to Variety, after initial
attempts to recast the role, Deadshot was written
out of the upcoming movie The Suicide Squad.
But this isn't quite as bad as
it sounds: According to sources,
the decision was made in order to allow Smith
the chance to reprise his role in the future.
For a good while, it appeared that Deathstroke
was poised to be a major fixture in the DCEU.
Joe Manganiello was cast in the role in September
2016, intended to be the villain of Ben Affleck's
The Batman. A year later, in October 2017,
Gareth Evans was in talks to write and direct
a solo Deathstroke movie starring Manganiello,
too. All of these developments occurred before
Deathstroke made his first DCEU appearance
in a post-credits scene for Justice League,
which teased him teaming up with Lex
Luthor to found the Legion of Doom.
Unfortunately, none of these plans for Deathstroke
ever came to fruition. First, Affleck's version
of The Batman fell apart. Matt Reeves took over
the project and put together a new cast, which
didn't include Manganiello. Additionally, the
Deathstroke solo movie never got off the ground.
In April 2020, Evans described his proposed
Deathstroke movie to Yahoo! Movies UK as:
"A lean story, that would be kind of an origin
of that character. Something that felt like it
could be 100 minutes or 110 minutes long, max
— not to go over the two hour period with it."
Plans for another Justice League
movie also never came to fruition,
leading to no follow-up on that Deathstroke
post-credits scene. Currently, there are
no plans to have Deathstroke show up in
any future DCEU movies. In October 2019,
Manganiello referenced his troubled experiences
with Deathstroke by telling Comic Book Resources:
"Someday I'll write a book about
it, but that time is... yeah."
Among the military personnel fixated on Superman
in Man of Steel was General Calvin Swanwick.
Played by Harry Lennix, Swanwick proved a useful
ally to Superman in the fight against General Zod.
In his second appearance in Batman
v. Superman: Dawn of Justice,
the character had gone from being a military
general to United States Secretary of Defense.
Lennix's prominence in the franchise
even extended off the screen.
At the 2013 San Diego International
Comic-Con, Zack Snyder had Lennix read
a passage from The Dark Knight Returns as a way
of announcing that the follow-up to Man of Steel
would pit Batman against Superman. Snyder also
planned to have Swanwick become a superhero
himself in Justice League. Per the storyboards
that Zack Snyder shared on his Vero account,
Swanwick was to eventually be revealed
as the cosmic being Martian Manhunter.
These plans, however, never came to pass.
After Snyder was taken off Justice League,
Swanwick was left out of the film's theatrical
cut. Swanwick hasn't been seen since Batman v.
Superman and no future DCEU movies have
announced plans to bring the character back.
In 2013's Man of Steel, Laurence
Fishburne appeared as the most
recent cinematic incarnation of
the Daily Planet chief Perry White.
For his take on the character,
Fishburne told ComicBook.com that
"Essentially, I used my model, my
inspiration really is the late Ed Bradley,
who was a CBS correspondent
on 60 Minutes for many years."
Fishburne reprised the role in the second
entry in Batman v. Superman: Dawn of Justice.
Since that 2016 feature, though, Fishburne's
Perry White has been absent from the DCEU.
This is partially due to scheduling conflicts on
the part of Fishburne. When asked to reprise the
White role in Justice League, Fishburne declined
the offer. He later told The Los Angeles Times:
"They asked me to come for a day, but
I couldn't work it out, schedule-wise.
And really, what do you need the
newspaperman in Justice League for?"
Fishburne subsequently noted that he
wasn't sure about his future in the DCEU.
In 2018, he revealed to Den of Geek:
"I don't think I'm still on call. I was
unfortunately unable to go do some work
on what turned out to be the Justice League
movie. I don't know that I need to go back
or if they'll have me back or not, but I
was grateful to have been a part of it."
Though a new Superman adventure could
see the character returning, for now,
the DCEU's Perry White appears
to have become yesterday's news.
Killer Croc made his live-action movie debut
in Suicide Squad, in which he was portrayed
by Adewale Akinnuoye-Agbaje. A member of the
titular group of supervillains, Croc managed
to survive the events of Suicide Squad and ended
the film with both a reduced prison sentence and
access to BET in his jail cell. However, unlike
some of his fellow Suicide Squad characters,
Killer Croc will not be returning for the
next installment in the franchise. But this
development seems to suit Akinnuoye-Agbaje
just fine. He told Yahoo! Movies UK:
"I don't think I need to
[do it again], to be honest.
I did it, I enjoyed it, it bought me
a Bentley and I will keep moving on."
Killer Croc being alive at the end of Suicide
Squad means the door is still open for his return,
however, should any subsequent DCEU movies
want to further explore the character.
For now, though, neither the DCEU
nor Adewale Akinnuoye-Agbaje is in
a rush to revisit the scaliest
member of the Suicide Squad.
"This is Katana. She's got my
back. She could cut all you in
half with one sword stroke,
just like mowing the lawn."
Ok, yeah, not the greatest intro in the world.
But Katana showed some pretty
extraordinary superpowers in Suicide Squad,
especially when compared to the more
grounded skills of some of her teammates.
Even with those abilities, though, Katana ended
up having a pretty small role in the movie.
This is primarily due to a number of her scenes
ending up on the cutting room floor, including
a sequence during which she became possessed by
Enchantress and attacked the other Suicide Squad
members. Sadly, her reduced presence in Suicide
Squad ended up mirroring her subsequent role in
the entire DCEU franchise. Since her debut, Katana
has been absent from all other DCEU properties,
including her team's follow-up movie. This is
despite actress Karen Fukuhara having a clear
vision of where she wanted to take the character
in future movies. As she once told ComicBook.com:
"I'd like to explore where she's from,
what kind of training she comes from — if she
gets a stand-alone movie that would be awesome!
There's so much story from the point of
her husband's death to her story leading
up to Suicide Squad — that's something
that I'd love to show on the screen."
Unfortunately, though she
may have Rick Flagg's back,
the DCEU doesn't have any plans
to bring Katana back just yet.
There are many superheroes in the DCEU, but
none have the technological prowess of Cyborg.
He made his first full-fledged appearance as
part of the titular superhero team in Justice
League after being introduced to audiences
via a cameo in Batman v. Superman. Originally,
the DCEU had big plans for Cyborg which
included the character co-starring in an
early version of the Flash movie. From there,
Cyborg was supposed to get his own solo movie,
entitled Cyborg, which was set
for an April 3rd 2020 release.
"Booyah."
However, those ambitions ultimately went
unfulfilled. Since Justice League in 2017,
Cyborg has made no further appearances
in the DCEU. Ray Fisher has said the lack
of movement for the solo Cyborg movie is
simply due to money. He told CinemaBlend:
"There's a ton of people making those
kinds of decisions behind the scenes.
And it would be a very, very costly movie to
make because it is so CGI heavy with Cyborg.
Because I'm the only member of the
League that's not in a practical costume.
You're going to be looking at
$200 million just to make it."
Despite the character's absence from the DCEU,
Fisher hasn't given up hope
on playing Cyborg again.
Fisher commented on the prospect of reprising
the role in a Twitch livestream by saying:
"Nothing's off the table [...] Knock on wood."
With no future appearances on the horizon, though,
the most tech-savvy DCEU hero has,
for now, been put in sleep mode.
Prior to the release of Suicide
Squad, theories abounded about
who Ike Barinholtz was playing in the film. Dr.
Hugo Strange was a particularly popular guess.
But if you're struggling to remember if
Barinholtz was even in Suicide Squad,
well, it's because he wasn't playing
an famous comic book character at all.
In reality, Barinholtz ended up playing a totally
original character by the name of Hunter Griggs.
Griggs was a sadistic prison guard at Belle
Reeve tasked with guarding the supervillains
that would make up the Suicide Squad team. In
the earliest scenes of the film, he's shown
perpetrating particularly nasty acts of abuse
against Deadshot and Harley Quinn. Eventually,
Griggs is taken captive by the Joker, but at this
point he pretty much vanishes from the movie.
"You're so screwed."
"What do you mean by that? What do you mean
by that? Harley, what do you mean by that?"
The audience is never shown Griggs' fate,
and the DCEU is apparently in no hurry to
clarify Harley's statement. Since Suicide
Squad, Griggs has failed to appear in any
other DCEU properties and he isn't a part
of the cast of The Suicide Squad. Though
pre-release speculation ran rampant over who
Hunter Griggs was, it turns out the character
wasn't all that important to Suicide Squad
— or, for that matter, the DCEU at large.
Batman v. Superman: Dawn of Justice was all
about showdowns between superheroes. But it
still had room for a supervillain. That adversary
was Superman foe Lex Luthor, here portrayed
by Jesse Eisenberg. The man who orchestrated
the titular duel between Batman and Superman,
Luthor is also responsible for creating Doomsday,
the creature that eventually kills Superman.
By the end of Batman v. Superman, Luthor has been
sent to prison, had his head shaved, and delivered
some vague warnings to Batman indicating that
he's aware of an impending attack by Darkseid.
Luthor's final moments in Batman v. Superman set
up plenty of different directions the character
could go down in future DCEU movies. However,
despite those cliffhangers, the DCEU version
of Luthor and his potential connections to
Darkseid have been almost totally ignored:
He's only appeared once since Batman v.
Superman, in a Justice League post-credits scene.
"To put it plainly, shouldn't
we have a league of our own?"
In the years since Justice League, no other
DCEU movies have even referenced this particular
supervillain. And with no upcoming DCEU movies
planning to end the character's absence,
even Eisenberg is doubtful he'll ever return
to the role of Lex Luthor. As he told MovieWeb:
"I probably won't do another. I don't know,
if they're making another
one, where I would be in it."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.